foreign
other question here this one's from
nastassia in Seattle Washington
I'm nastassia from Seattle and also a
patreon subscriber so I'd love to get
your perspective on how to communicate
with other people specifically men who
are interested in pursuing me
romantically or want to sexually
exclusive situation with me
that I am ethically non-monogamous and
currently exploring solo polyamory
I come from a Catholic monogamous based
traditional upbringing but during
college separated myself from religion
and accepted the fact that I am bisexual
I've had long serious relationships that
have been both open and traditionally
monogamous however I kept those details
to myself and very rarely if ever
mentioned to others
over the last couple years I've decided
to lean into the e m Community a bit
more and become more openly confident in
non-traditional exploration and
lifestyle choices with that comes
learning to navigate this topic to
friends family and new intimate partners
I don't shout from the hilltops about it
or feel like e m is the only thing I'll
pursue for the rest of my life but I am
trying to practice how to explain it
early on enough so I don't accidentally
hurt someone lastly well I'm currently
single I have a deep connection with a
couple I see semi-regularly already and
am invested in prioritizing that
relationship
how do I explain that to other people
who may want to go out with me
exclusively additionally is it common or
expected that as a solo poly person I
need to share with everyone that I am
actively talking to or sleeping with
other people or is it fine to just say
I'm e m and leave it at that I'm not
sure how transparent that needs to be
Aubry what I'm hearing here
to some extent from nastasia's question
is
how can I be in an open relationship
without being judged by my friends
family community the people around me in
a society that actually judges and worse
shames people for having something that
is anywhere outside the norm and by the
way this is where minimalism comes in as
well as soon as we started talking about
letting go of excess things and letting
go of relationship clutter letting go of
calendar clutter career clutter whatever
it might be you get judged by the people
around you but no more so or the place
you're judged most probably is in this
Arena here of ethical non-monogamy or
open relationship
yeah so the one thing is is that those
people who are bought into the story of
you know there's one way to do a
relationship and that's the only way
they're going to defend that actually
pretty vehemently and and what I've seen
is the reason they're going to defend it
is they're actually scared of what this
opens up in their own mind because a lot
of people the people who I've found had
the most difficulty with accepting this
were the people who were a little bit
frustrated in their relationship but
they've convinced themselves this is the
only way and you just have to deal with
it but when you say no there's another
way they're like no there's not another
way and they try to close that option
down so it doesn't start to play with
their mind and give them a possibility
like what you mean there's a different
type of structure that I could use like
they don't really want to engage that so
to start to see that and know that
actually you living this life is
challenging and it's threatening to
those people who've accepted the
compromise of all right this is just the
way things are I'm not really that happy
but nonetheless this is the way it is
there's no other option you give them
another option they're going to come at
you and and that's just something that
you have to be aware of and have
compassion for them and their experience
and be gentle with it and just you know
I've never I never wanted to push I
never wanted to get into an argument you
just say hey this works for me this is
what this is what I'm called to this is
what my heart and spirit are called to
so that's how I dealt with the people
who had those questions but that isn't
to say that I didn't lose friendships
over being non-monogamous so I lost some
very very important friendships in my
life why do you think that is
I think it was because it challenged one
or the other of the of the partners
maybe one partner was afraid that their
partner might actually want somebody
else and so this opened up this
Pandora's Box like oh I hope my partner
doesn't you know get around Aubry and
Whitney too long and then get these
crazy ideas and start wanting to see
other people so that was one and then
the other was people who were actually
frustrated and like don't tell me
there's another option don't tell me
that you can be with other lovers and it
could be okay because I can't engage in
that you know like I can't actually
accept that so it was typically one or
both of those two reasons that that
happened so to go to our second part of
the question which is how transparent do
you need to be and when
for me you know I was also single at
certain different points and when you're
single you date and there's a certain
point where you talk about if you're
dating other people there's not in my
mind a supposition that if you go on a
date with somebody that I'm not seeing I
know I'm not dating anybody else you
know like that conversation comes you
know and and that conversation sometimes
comes early and sometimes comes after a
couple dates where you realize like yeah
you know I'm seeing a couple people and
you're still dating you're not like
together committed in a relationship
with anybody so at the point where
things start to evolve then I share it
now that isn't to say that sometimes
right out of the gate I didn't check
because I was very public you know I did
podcasts on non-monogamy I made posts I
wrote newsletters so it was very out
there so I didn't want them anybody to
find out and be like hey man I just
Googled you and saw this podcast on
polyamory so I was very upfront with it
but I also don't feel like there's
you're compelled to share all the
details until that relationship becomes
sexual and evolved in a way and I think
at the point that it's sexual it is
ethical to share all of your partnership
so that somebody knows that look this is
where the this is the field this is
where it's at but if it's a first date
and you're out on coffee you're just
getting to know each other you don't
need to go hey and by the way I'm seeing
this couple and I'm really feeling about
it you don't even know if you like the
person yet you know like you don't even
know if you get along yeah you know so I
think there's a point where it becomes
your ethical responsibility but that
point isn't immediate you know it's you
it's something that you can kind of feel
after you decide whether you've built a
rapport with that person that you're
seeing yeah did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free